and I'm gonna start with this year tweet
from none other than chenk yuger of The
Young Turks Jank tweeted I was watching
a random Ben Shapiro clip because of a
segment we're going to do today it's
amazing and hilarious how panicked they
are that they're losing the culture War
it's true they are losing lol
I'd like to point out
um
I'm not going to get too deep in on this
one but I'm gonna explain to you what
matters to me in terms of the culture
War now first I'll say I don't know that
they if it's referring to conservatives
are losing
um it's certainly not just conservatives
on one side and just left us on the
other there's a whole network of
different political factions obviously
the intellectual dark web is a bunch of
typically progressives who are not in
line with Chen Huger but um I just want
to mention that on May 31st 2019 Cheng
yuger defended child drag shows where a
child dances on stage and gets money
thrown at him and said it wasn't child
abuse when he's brought into adult
venues I'm sickened by this and you want
to talk about why the culture War
matters because I don't think 11 year
old boys should be taking off their
clothing on stage for a bunch of adult
men who are handing dollar bills to him
that's just one thing we can talk about
but that really bothered me if Jen
cougar thinks he's he's winning that one
then Heaven Help Us but I digress that's
just that gets me heated Charlie you are
running an organization that actually is
working with young people so maybe
there's some hope I suppose yeah I mean
the question of whether we're winning
the culture war or not is an interesting
one I think there are certain fronts
that were definitely winning on it's a
multi-front war and there's some things
that we're definitely losing on I mean
we are we're losing the kind of
corporate HR Battle of whether or not
the companies that we purchase our
products from are actually going to
represent their customers or represent
present the values of their customers
definitely losing on that front and
until it actually hits the long-term
bottom line of some of these companies
that's not going to change but I think
you see from the what I think is the
closest thing to the Tea Party Movement
in 2010 which is the school board kind
of Uprising which is organic and
exciting and out of nowhere that these
ideas when actually presented in the
public light are unbelievably unpopular
and wokeism for lack of a better term
has been able to kind of sneak into
these different institutions because
it's disguised itself under these sort
of banner terms kind of communicated by
people that have the trust of the
citizenry but the more people learn
about it the less popular they actually
are so I think it's actual if we do our
job I think it's inevitable that we're
going to be able to push back against
some of this the old some of the biggest
issues we have though is that it seems
as if the people with financial and
cultural and corporate power are
completely indifferent about out the
needs wants or interests of the actual
people and they're willing to crush you
if you disagree with them yeah yeah the
the for whatever reason
powerful corporate interests be it
because they're infiltrated as opposed
by ideal ideologues they're they're more
scared of the left and they are of the
right the right can start a boycott and
it rarely ever has a big impact but if
the left comes out what what do we just
have this is a hilarious Tweet someone
put a sticker it said I heart JK
rattling on a train and so some random
Twitter account tweeted to the Metro I
can't remember which country I think it
was the UK and said it's transphobic and
they were like we're so sorry we'll
we'll get rid of it immediately that's
how insane it is so there's that bias
but I will say when it comes to the
Loudoun County uh uh the parents there
this is like one where the big fight is
happening it's actually we're we're
about a minute from from Loudoun County
about 20 minutes from the actual school
board but these parents started seeing
not just critical race Theory they
started seeing critical theory in
general this Marxist view of oppressed
versus oppressor it includes critical
gender Theory and once they realized
what was happening they snapped they
were like no way you're teaching me my
kids these things now I want to go back
just briefly and not not not to the
exact subject matter of the of The Young
Turks and what they were defending but
in that segment you know I watched it
because I'm thinking like what is Jenky
euger actually support in his culture
war in that video clip Jordan klepper I
think his name is Comedy Central guy
he's just like it's so great to see this
young child saying he wants to be an
advocate they don't know at all what's
going on with that kid and they don't
care they are so tribalist tribalistic
that their whole their whole thing is
just and if the right hates it we gotta
like it
suppose that's where we're at huh that's
that was why I brought up earlier that I
think that anyone that wants someone to
lose this culture war is missing the
point I think that if and you were
saying well hey that's child abuse you
gotta you gotta make them lose and I was
like my thing is before the show you
mentioned yes before the show if if if
if we can make them not do child abuse
anymore then they actually win they
might it's not we're not trying to
destroy people and make them leave we
want everyone to win by changing these
bizarre behaviors and like kind of
create a better Society I think so that
everybody wins yeah and the the bottom
line of all of this is the death of
objectivity right so the basically the
chunk world view which is nihilistic in
nature is that well who's to say that
that's a bad thing it might be
somebody's truth that it's a good thing
that the child can dance it all comes
back down and that's that that if you if
you really go down to its most basic
argument is can we as human beings use
reason in our faculty and our
Consciousness to come to some agreed
upon terms of what is good what is bad
what is evil and what is true and this
used to be a basically a non-negotiable
tenet of Western society which is that
we're going to agree that there is a
moral law governing us as human beings I
would go as far to say that we agreed
that there was a Transcendent order and
almost every single one of these
initiatives tries to change the Paradigm
completely of how the citizenry or the
population views that and so in in its
Essence it's it's deconstructionist to
say the least do you uh you know we
mentioned that you guys I I don't know
what the right word is but you
communicate with younger people high
school students well they're going to
grade school man they're going younger
yeah they're a lot of babies they're
going to nurseries and younger I mean
and this is all part of a broader
project of of trying to almost push
nihilism with Evangelistic fervor and
there's an exciting part of this for us
because For the first time in a long
time we're no longer really having these
like robust discussions on corporate tax
rates like that's really boring actually
we're now actually arguing very basic
human philosophy philosophy which is do
you think there is meaning to your
existence and if so do you want to
create an order or a civil framework to
reflect that meaning that that is that
is the true Collision point we're seeing
you know when I when I I perhaps it's
very I don't know the right word is
hyperbolic or um it's a straw man to
look at Jank huger's you know one of the
worst things he's defended but I I
genuinely think that's a good an
important point to bring up when he's
talking about why they're winning the
culture War why it's these are some of
the things that they're actively
defending but I will point out
you know look I don't consider myself a
conservative but when I look at the
right we mentioned this briefly before
the show Steve Steve King was his name
right the the rep he tweeted something
about white nationalism he said he said
something like why was it a bad thing
and then what happens he gets primaried
he gets he first he gets kicked off all
his committees they're a lot Republicans
are like we're not having it then he
gets primary someone runs against
someone like no we're not having it now
he's out now he's the Republicans have
no problem in fact to a fault going
after their own because of ideological
Purity we talk about the left and the
circular firing squad but I mean look at
the Republicans going after Marjory
Taylor green there's pros and there's
cons there I can look to Republicans and
be like see look when that guy said a
racism they said goodbye but when ilhan
Omar comes out and says whatever they
defend it when you get something that is
clearly objectionable to regular parents
they come out and defend it and call
these parents right Wingers they try to
dox them they call them alt-right
whatever this is regular mom man it's a
regular mom who lives in the DC area
who's upset about what's happening yeah
I mean there's there's this big
difference between the cut of moral
universes that the left and right now
habit and the left is much less about
principle and much more about the ends
that they think are ultimately moral and
I don't necessarily think it's nihilism
but I think it is ultimately defined by
this kind of like you know anti-racism
anti-discrimination ethic that that's
the only Soul that's basically the only
real good anti-discrimination
um in in a certain context right I won't
say that the left is purely
interdiscriminatory they have well not
the fat blind spots I mean that their
their their ideology is literally
pro-discrimination but
anti-discrimination and that they're
like hey let this six-year-old dance
doesn't matter that he's six don't
discriminate equity and liberationist I
guess right they don't discriminate
based on a lot of things that's a true
point right and so so that ends up like
being this totalizing moral code and
it's so totalizing that it justifies
basically tolerating any sort of bad
behavior from the people advocating for
it right because it's like this we are
ruthlessly pragmatic in the service of
this goal that we think is completely
the single most important thing in the
world so even if the people we rely on
to push it you know our Act activists or
whatever are behaving corruptly doesn't
matter who cares this this I got freaked
out by a meme on Facebook somebody
posted this like image and it was like
they said I can't remember exactly what
it was it was about Derek Chauvin going
to prison
and I was thinking about the idea of
Derek shopping going to prison they said
something related to the hard work and
the Press I remember now they said if it
wasn't for that little girl that young
woman who filmed that Chauvin would have
gotten away with it and I thought about
that I said I responded with don't
forget the violence and the terror if it
wasn't for anti-fun black lives matter
Chauvin may have actually gotten away
with it it was only because of the
violence and the extreme pressure and
the men with machine guns forced to come
and defend the jurors the jurors were
scared enough to say we're going to
convict
these people liked that idea you know I
said something that in fact I get a like
on it they're like that's right if it
wasn't for the activists and the people
who went out and smashed those windows
they may have let Chauvin go you got to
think about what that means
all of the innocent people that were
suffering because the left was angry
about one man and the action he took and
it was an egregious action regardless
like whatever ends up happening the guy
got convicted was so we can say look we
don't like that people died
but that meant the mentality of these
people is
it is better that five million innocent
people suffer than one guilty person
Escape it's the opposite of Blackstone
it's it's Otto von Bismarck that's he
said it was better that 10 innocent
people suffer than one guilty person
it's originally Blackstone but yeah for
sure it's the opposite Blackstone is the
good one yeah we believe in Freedom he
was the one that basically created the
common law tradition that our Founders
embraced Benjamin Franklin repeated it
differently but you're exactly right and
I mean that was the that was the most
public hostage situation in the in
American history which was basically the
activists were like we're gonna take all
decent Society hostage if you don't give
us the verdict we want and you could say
we want about Derek shovin he did not
get a fair trial he just didn't that one
of the jurors was absolutely compromised
if you go to a BLM Incorporated rally
and you lie on your jury application
form same thing happened to Roger Stone
I don't care if you're a far left-wing
socialist it says very clearly and will
would know this better either in the
sixth seventh or eighth amendment that
you get a you get a fair and quick and
Speedy process of a juror of your peers
and it must be impartial and it wasn't
I'll I'll throw it to you in a second
but I'll make one more point my opinion
is that the moment the judge said there
is no venue in Minnesota by which we
could have a a trial removed from the
circumstances of George Floyd my opinion
was throw it out if we believe that it
is better that 10 guilty persons Go free
than one innocent person suffer and you
cannot have a fair trial and you know it
charges dropped case dismissed sure and
I I just think it's simple it doesn't
relieve the judge of the obligation to
try and make it as Fair as possible
right and so move it to a more remote
location that isn't directly next to
where it happened but I think the other
really interesting thing is that you
know the same people who are talking
about how a 22 and a half year sentence
for an unintentional homicide as being
too lenient or call themselves criminal
justice reformers and worried about mass
incarceration right like if anything I
mean the maximum sense in Minnesota was
only 30 years this is not you know what
for for the second degree murder charge
which is really legally questionable
because they use the felony murder
statute and the felony in this case was
the assault so it's the same thing that
caused the murder which means that that
theory of second-degree murder would
swallow up manslaughter entirely well
and the big lie the whole thing is that
race had nothing to do with this nothing
yeah and that that's the big the biggest
of all lies was that this was all
racially motivated and I mean Derek
Chauvin interacted with dozens of black
people before that encounter and it was
George Floyd that was trading
counterfeit bills it was George Floyd
that was acting
out of normal behavior and asked to be
on the ground I'm not Derek chovin's
defense attorney what I am though is
trying to dispel this overarching
narrative that dominated us that Derek
Chauvin was like The Reincarnation of
Nathan Bedford Forrest which there's no
evidence to show that in fact Keith
Ellison came out and said we have no
evidence this is a hate crime I wonder
how many people know who that guy is
though Nathan Bedford Forrest he's the
founder of the KKK they never tried to
prove intent right that's a key thing to
remember they never if you listen to
that whole trial you would never heard
them say Chauvin intended to kill right
this person that never happened and the
first medical autopsy from the Hennepin
County said that this is a drug overdose
the second one said that this was
because of NECA asphyxiation
and it was convicted by Drew your peers
we trust the process the judge and
themselves though himself said look
based on Maxine Waters comments you
might have actually
um let's say means or a reason for a
retrial so this was nothing more than a
hostage situation by BLM Incorporated
yeah yeah that was the alternate Joe who
came out and said I was scared of
retaliation they come to my house thanks
for checking out this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast if you want to see
the full show come back to this channel
youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time